foreign
[Music]
yes hey man people been talking about
Earth's core lately it's been in the
news it's been in the news
clearly it's slowing down or
something and now we all have we have to
wait for scientists to get into a
machine that will burrow to the Center
of the Earth
and where the machine gets stronger as
the temperature goes up right you know
um okay
um and they might as well have found uh
well what what's the wakando metal oh
because it's the same vibranium
vibranium yeah might as well just be
vibranium uh yes the latest news is that
the core is slowing down right and so
that means we're gonna have to go there
and speed it back yeah exactly
so let me just back up I don't claim to
be a geologist okay and maybe we should
do a whole show on this I think and
bring in one of my geology colleagues a
geophysicist colleagues but I know Earth
is a planet so let me speak of Earth
that the way an astrophysicist would
speak of Earth okay right so when
planets formed they are not solid
initially right all right they're first
gaseous and then with enough pressure
they might become liquid but in any case
once a gravitational field is set up
then
heavy Things fall to the middle right
because it's not solid yet okay
everything's fall to the middle and of
all the available ingredients that are
just hanging around in the formation of
a star system you get things like you
know hydrogen and oxygen and silicon and
nitrogen and carbon and you keep going
and as you get to the heavier elements
in the periodic table iron is very
common in the universe and nickel these
ingredients are heavier than silicon and
oxygen and and carbon so they fall to
the middle okay and what floats on the
top
our light things like rocks
okay there you go we don't think of sio2
silicon dioxide that's a that's a major
active ingredient in rocks we don't
think of them as light we think of rocks
as heavy right but they're the lightest
thing going on earth when Earth is
forming and they all float to the top so
our crust is made of light solid
ingredients and everything below it is
made of heavier ingredients like a like
a delicious metal pie metal pie exactly
so nature precifts the ingredients
and what's interesting is Proto planets
that did this and then solidified
protoplanets might get slammed later on
and their bits and pieces break into
asteroids so some asteroids are made of
crustal material others are made of core
material
gotcha so asteroids made of core
material are pre-sifted heavy elements
such as like I said iron and nickel gold
silver all these heavy elements are
pre-sorted for you if you select a
metallic asteroid versus a rocky
asteroid right okay now there's more of
the rocky stuff than the metallic stuff
so most asteroids are are rocky some
asteroids are metallic and that's that's
what we have out there so now we have
Earth which was thankfully not broken
apart it is retained its Integrity okay
okay but by the way their transition
zones where the metals are trying to
descend
and the rocky stuff is trying to ascend
and by then the Earth froze
solidified froze for its whatever the
ingredients are solidified and it's
stuck in place and this is how you get
like these or what do you call these
um deposits these loads these deposits
okay they can be trapped in places
frozen out from whatever was going on
previously all right but the bulk of
those materials have been have separated
let's make that clear okay okay so now
uh Earth has retained heat from its past
okay and it's so it from the formation
heat it is still trying to cool down
right all right Mars is smaller than we
are
and it so it has more surface compared
to its volume you do the math on that it
turns out to be correct and the more
surface you have the more you can
radiate away your heat gotcha that's why
small animals mammals have to eat way
more food than larger mammals relative
to their body weight because they're
radiating away their heat much faster
because the the if you look at their
surface area compared to their volume
all right this is why babies need Extra
Protection uh for their body temperature
to protect it okay so so it's all it's
it I mean we did a whole surface area
thing I remember I was about to say yes
correct it relates to that okay so we
have we have less surface area for our
volume it'll take us longer to cool
the consequences of this leftover heat
is that we on the crust
which is cooled solid because it's
touching the outer air we are floating
on this plastic liquid mantle oh the
Lake of Fire okay and so we are floating
and that's how you get continental drift
right and occasionally that mantle can
punch through and you've got a volcano
nice
so you get earthquakes and volcanoes
from a lot of this leftover heat but
let's keep going down okay down and now
the mixture in the earth is changing
and it is so hot the iron has liquefied
so the outer core of Earth is liquid
iron damn
okay sorry how hot it is that's gotta be
hot it's hot it was it's better it's hot
as the sun's surface whoa yeah about 10
000 degrees you'll melt iron okay take
that Dante
Hell hath no fury like Earth's core
that's right right so now we have this
liquid outer layer right okay well why
isn't it liquid all the way through
because as you keep going further down
the pressure is so high
that it's compactified into a solid look
at that yes so it's just as hot but the
pressure is so great it will not allow
it to melt yes oh my God yes so you have
a solid iron core filter that's
surrounded by a liquid liquid powder
what means the solid core
it's kind of independent of the rest of
the planet yes because it's only a
liquid it's like lubrication even yes
think about it that way oh my God it's
like a lava lamp
yes Chuck it's exactly like 11. no I
don't I forgot what love they have these
blobs yeah
right right exactly so how do you know
all this like you've been to the Center
of the Earth you kind of with our
pressure waves yes for every earthquake
uh-huh once you find the epicenter which
is not too hard you can triangulate on
it you then as long as you have
earthquake sensors scattered around the
world you can time how long it takes
that signal to reach you
mm-hmm in so doing you can infer the
interior structure of the Earth because
different materials will transmit those
waves at different rates than other
materials so the interior becomes the
medium and then you're correct and then
you're measuring the wave as it moves to
the medium and that allows you to
correct information you can learn if
they're edges between sharp boundaries
between one medium and another right
occasionally you can have a wave that
reflects off of a surface it's a very
complex map that you make from all of
these signals when they're done and it's
not just earthquakes you know it also
gives you these data underground nuclear
tests oh wow and those are especially
valuable right
geophysically because you know exactly
where the test occurred right so there's
no there's less uncertainty in where
where the epicenter is you hear that
North Korea where are on to you
so so so you add up all these data and
you can reconstruct what the center of
the earth of what the entire structure
of the Earth would be like wow okay
without ever having gone there that's
amazing yeah and these are pressure
basically sound waves exactly okay
that's crazy yeah so it's pretty cool
yeah it is so another thing
we know from physics
that moving electrical charges create
magnetic fields right okay Faraday first
notice this
and vice versa okay so you can move a
charge there's a magnetic field that's
created around it you can
take a take a charge
um move it in a magnetic field and the
magnetic field will induce a current
right in the wire so so Faraday did this
so you had a magnetic field took a wire
move the wire through the magnetic field
and and an amp meter move the needle
moved because current was introduced
into the wire that's how electricity is
made today exactly what a turbine is all
right you're moving wires through a
magnetic field creating a current wow
and with power plants everything about a
power plant is so that you can sit there
and move wires through a magnetic field
so that's so amazing it's it's such a
simple simple concept it's a simple
concept
it's amazing feeds the civilization when
Faraday first demonstrated this and
there's a just a little meter it's like
that's cute Michael okay that's Michael
been doing today okay there's a little
meter that's a nice toy and there's a
famous quote maybe apocryphal when asked
when he asked for more funding and he
says of what value is this to the
British crown and and the British Empire
and he said I don't know sir but one day
you will tax it
wow that's how you make electricity all
right let's get back to the earth that
is also how you talk to any government
anywhere yes yes yes if you're a
scientist and an inventor yeah so you
have this liquid layer you have a liquid
layer
then the iron
can move within that liquid and iron is
an electrical conductor as we've known
since childhood with the iron filings on
the on the magnets on the magnets when
they see the paper yeah so when you have
these electrons
provided by the iron moving it creates a
magnetic field and that is the origin of
Earth's magnetic field there you go
that's the origin that's super cool okay
and it's something called a Dynamo
phenomenon where you have the
circulation and this continues and by
the way as is true for the Sun and in
many astrophysical objects the Dynamo
runs a course
of life where it gets stronger then it
gets weaker and then it gets stronger
again but with the opposite polarity no
I'm like a phoenix baby oh so we have
evidence
from Iron that has been spewed forth
from volcanoes that then solidified in
place capturing the magnetic field at
the time that the iron that the field
was laid and we see evidence every
several hundred thousand years of the
magnetic field of Earth flipping back
and forth oh look at that so that's on a
cycle okay the sun's magnetic field
flips on an 11-year cycle
okay son has an 11-year cycle and every
11 years it gets more luminosity and
less Luminosity but every 11 years it'll
do the same thing but with the polls
reversed okay okay okay so now let's get
back to this
the core basically rotates with the
surface of the Earth
but occasionally we'll rotate a little
faster all righty slow down slap and
then a little slower okay all right so
we're all comparing it relative to we on
the surface and the recent measurement
showed that the solid core of the Earth
was trailing behind Earth's surface
the fact that something new but there's
a there's a periodicity of this that
they're estimating to be about 70 years
where it'll slow down uh catch up again
overtake us slow and and then return so
so these measurements are affirmations
that the core has its own sort of
rhythms inside the liquid iron within
the rest of the earth that's rotating
around it all I know is this whole thing
was worth it just to hear the word
periodicity oh I mean I don't know where
we pulled that we use that word all the
time oh my God The rhythms of the
universe uh to find them we track their
periodicity oh look at this let me tell
you something if you gave that to like
um
you know the people like always and stay
free and not they they would love you
because that is that's a beautiful word
I'll tell you right now
you will you're talking about feminine
products yeah on television that's what
you're talking about there's so much
there's so much like stigma
unnecessarily uh
right right but instead it's just like
um hi yes I'm gonna need um some
periodicity products thank you I'm
totally cool with that okay all right
thank you Mom send me to the store to
get your periodicity stuff okay
subscribe
all right so anyway so we're still
trying to figure out what it means that
we have this 70-year cycle uh in the
center of the Earth but right now
Earth's magnetic field is weakening okay
and but we still it's not it's not going
to go away in anybody's lifetime so
nothing I wouldn't worry about it right
um and by the way there's no
no evidence of Extinction when the the
magnetic field went to zero when it
clicked right it flips there's no so
because people say well the magnetic
fields protecting us from the dangers
yeah the sun right and and maybe but
whatever damage it caused this it's not
even a blip in the in the fossil record
so and and the fish don't care right the
fish are underwater they don't the
particles don't hit them ever all right
so they don't care everybody's fine
except Harold he was in the wrong place
at the wrong time Harold we're sorry
that is totally a fish name
who got fried when the polls flipped
that's what you get for trying to use
those legs that you should you should
have stayed in the ocean you should stay
in Ocean House did anytime revolve yet
all right we got to end it there all
right that's my little bit but we I'd
like to hear this all from the mind and
the the brain of a geologist so we'll
try to do a whole show on that yeah it's
all fascinating I love it you got it all
right that's been yet another explainer
this one on Earth's core uh as as only
an astrophysicist can describe it uh
look for our full show that we haven't
done yet we will on
for the core from the point of view of a
geophysicist on Star Talk explainers
Neil deGrasse Tyson
foreign